guys welcome to the just pearly things
youtube channel and welcome to the
pregame
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos while
you're at it sign up for our memberships
for our exclusive behind-the-scenes
content like the other day ish lost a
bet and he had to buy me and just dinner
we are releasing that video this week
and if you want to see it sign up for
our memberships also guys a like is free
okay whatever the audience is right now
50 of you should have liked the video
because it is free it doesn't cost a
thing hit that subscribe button while
you're at it too
so today i have a lovely panel full of
guests why don't we go around everyone
say your name your age
and then since the topic today is
abortion why don't we
say if you're religious and if you're
pro-life or pro-choice
cool so we're back again name's eddie
i'm 28 and i'm from london
as for my stance on it um i'm pro-life
i'll say i have a religious background
but i identify as spiritual now
hi guys my name is natasha i'm 18 and
i'm from london
um i'm a prayer life or pro-choice
[Music]
i haven't really made up my mind you
know i'm still thinking and am i
religious i believe in god i just
believe that there's one god that's what
i believe in
hi i'm tegan i'm 19 i'm from wales uh i
am religious um more spiritual
and i'm pro-choice
hi guys i'm daniel i'm 24.
i would say with my religious background
i am and my instinctive answer is
pro-life
okay so
um
my first question
is
are you aware of when or how far
abortion is legal in the uk
so so it is um it is legal up to six
months
um
and so the interesting thing i was
researching this and it's up to 24 weeks
and i googled the um
earliest that a baby has like survived
in abortion or non-abortion um
like
you know being born yeah yeah yeah
they're the earliest they've been born
yeah and i found out that it's 21 weeks
so there's a video um that i'd like okay
also guys this video is very graphic um
so if you don't want to sorry if you
don't want to see it
don't look now because it's kind of
gross
um
okay and i just want to know if you guys
think
that this looks like a baby or not
does it look yeah so you can just play
that
it'd be interesting to find out in my
opinion
it would be interesting to find out how
common it would be for a baby to survive
at that age
no it's it's not common no it's not i
think that might factor into the the
majority
um
i don't think the majority survived that
early that's not common
um but
it has so the fact that there's a chance
yeah okay interesting
um
so i'm just curious if we go around the
panel um
it kind of went off again
who keeps exiting out of it
um okay so
do you guys think that that is too soon
you can go around
um
after seeing that
and the fact that there is a chance that
a kid can survive that procedure at that
age um it's definitely too soon 24 weeks
yeah okay
um i'll be so honest i feel like wait do
you mean tuition isn't too late or like
um
oh i guess yeah too late yeah
do you think that's too too late to get
yeah
it's way way way too late way too late
100 way too late yeah yeah way too late
so when do you guys think that life
begins
a scientific standpoint
is there really a scientific standpoint
on this
um
no the scientific standpoint is that
conception because there's a unique dna
sequence that is created when the sperm
and the egg meet
and that dna sequence has the kids
things like the kids personality their
eye color yeah they're like it has um
it's a completely it's a completely
different genetic code from the mom and
the dots
but when
do you think
because there's there's a little bit of
debate in the like between pro-lifers
and pro-choicers about when exactly life
begins
and when that's human
i used to think like when it was when
the baby was actually born okay but then
you think of like
babies who are born way too early
they're still still alive and they still
survive and they they grow up like
this is definitely not when they're born
but i just don't know like at a specific
time when that would be okay yeah i
don't know because it's a thing where
um
with
the fetus or the zygote everyone will
call it
the heart starts beating that four weeks
that's what i learned in school that the
heart starts being in four weeks
so you think four weeks
yeah i mean that's when the heart starts
beating because
but no it can be debatable because
animals have heartbeats as well do you
get it yeah so that is a bit of debate
that is a bit of a debate but i
partially agree
four weeks okay four weeks
i was gonna say i think arguably
my answer probably tiered towards
that idea of when the baby can actually
survive without support so if that baby
could be born at let's say five weeks
and live
then that should be the calf point but
if that baby can be born up to 21 weeks
and lived then maybe that should be the
cut off point but i think we need to try
and understand when that cutoff point is
for when the baby can actually survive
in this reality
as the the cutoff point because uh
before that then the baby's gonna die
regardless is that really life if the
babies can't survive so the argument
that i often hear is that like you could
use that argument with older people that
need to rely on something else to
survive because they're gonna die
regardless
and and the other thing that i hear is
that even kids under the age of two have
to rely on someone to survive because
otherwise they would die regardless yeah
but the thing is yeah you were talking
about cutoff points right it's like
everyone is different we all have a
different unique set of gene codes that
type of thing so the cut output for
everyone will be different regardless
because i'm no same to you i'm not um
like me and you we've got different
genes obviously me and paul got
different genes like
the unique cut-off point would be
different to everyone because everyone's
unique we all have our own genetic codes
and stuff like that so for me i would
say the cutoff point should be where we
can find a conclusive answer as to if
this baby is born at this point in time
there is no chance of survival
whatsoever regardless of what apparatus
or what support is needed to take that
baby it bring that baby into this world
so so then okay this is the problem with
that argument
is that
technology advances
and the cutoff point in 2022 is very
different than it was 50 years ago
then it should be adaptive it should be
something that's that is that's stagnant
it should change with as technology
progresses so as things develop then
there needs to be a re a
re-understanding of what that might be
it shouldn't just be like we shouldn't
follow the same principles of what we
had in the 19th century or the 20th
century
20th centuries i think that that should
change over time
i have a question what when was the um
cut-off point 50 years ago as to what he
said
50 years ago yeah um
oh no well
no i mean i don't know what the cutoff
used to be for abortion um i know in
2017 in the uk that was when it became
publicly funded and you see the number
of abortions skyrocket yeah yeah um but
no i don't know what the cutoff used to
be but i know that technology is
advancing and they're able to
save women that go into labor early
earlier and earlier and earlier so you
think technology has a um
interrelation with the amount of
abortions that has been scared skyrock
skyrocketing no i think that when
they're free
more people get them okay
um i think that technology that the
baby's development stays the same
regardless so no matter what the
technology was 150 years ago like the
baby's development what this was the
same but we can save the kids earlier
and earlier and earlier
so it begs the question if say 50 100
years ago we could only save them up to
seven or up to seven months let's say
then
they but they were allowing abortion say
up to six
but like they it then in essence they
were killing those kids because that
person could have survived outside of
the womb yeah so
the issue with like the argument that
you're giving is that
technology could progress and maybe
they'll save babies at four months in 50
years you just don't know and that's why
i should be adaptive that's why it
should change it should be something
that should be consistently revisited as
the technology develops so it shouldn't
be a one-size-fits-all
type um kind of um
look at the situation it should be
technology's developed x amount of times
we can save babies up until this amount
of time
therefore the abortion rate or the
abortion time limit should be should be
consistent with what the technology says
sorry do you say save babies
say because i thought abortion was well
sorry well
as in to not have to abort the baby to
put it correctly okay but as as paul
said girlsy the question is
when do you think life starts
so it's like obviously the
you know the um
you gave kind of the biology of how like
when you're actually going through that
conception you're already like passing
on characteristics and things to to make
that baby into a fetus which eventually
will be born so it's like
to me that sounds like that's when life
starts because life is literally like
whilst you're having sex like life is
about to literally
the process to do you know what i mean
so it's like
but i guess what does life mean to you
then like is this life
or is
the process of sex life because i think
that's where it that's why it becomes
more of a moral i don't think we have
that answer is the process is the
process of sex life yeah so like
obviously once you in once you
inseminate a woman you're saying that
obviously you're passing on certain
characteristics and colds etc
is that your understanding of life
no it's not it's it's when the sperm and
the egg meet that's when the new genetic
code is created so you can have sex with
someone and there's no life created
so yeah we inseminate a woman so yeah
yeah okay when the baby yeah okay so
when the sperm and the egg meet that's
when there's a unique genetic code and
this has the baby's eye color it has
their personality traits it has um
how tall they're going to be like it
it's a it's completely it's a different
code unique from the mother and the
fathers
yeah i agree but it's not like that is
life i think it's the process to the
beginning of life oh yeah very much so
and animals do instinctively as well
like you like you said you
see what i'm saying they do it because
that's that's what they're supposed to
do we're meant to carry life on i mean
of course yeah
that's that's never going to change you
know when you think about it though as
soon as you
think you're pregnant you'll do a
pregnancy test and it's like well two
weeks you can go as early as two weeks
and you think oh [ __ ] there's a life in
me so you know that you've just done a
pregnancy test you're pregnant there's a
life okay so maybe
yeah it starts that really doesn't it
because that's when you find out you're
pregnant now so i'm curious what makes
you you said you're pro-choice what
makes you pro-choice then
um
just depending on if you can
bring up this child financially stable
for this child relationship status like
is it gonna grow up in like a good
environment if not then
the only way out i guess is aborting the
baby just so it's like in a better place
better what i'm saying but like so i
have a question for you because i hear
this a lot
but that kind of sounds like you're
saying poor kids lives are less valuable
than no no no no no no no no no no i
know you don't mean it that way no i
don't mean it this is just how it sounds
right it sounds like that but like
wouldn't you want
sometimes it's like not poor kids it's
kids with absolutely nothing okay and
they end up like maybe just
dying anyways unfortunately like they
have absolutely nothing
do you know what i mean like some people
will have kids and you hear stories like
they left out in the streets on the
sidewalk literally to die
like wouldn't you just want to get rid
of it because actually do you guys have
it here in the us you can just leave a
kid at a fire station and they'll put it
like they'll take it so what
if they're in there okay guys
i'm not sure we have it here oh no
no in the us it's like um if they're
like they'll take a kid no questions
asked and like figure out how to get
them and i don't know what happens after
but yeah that's like a common thing in
the us
yeah
but but it's interesting because you
kind of just said the same thing but in
a different way
what do you mean so yeah
yeah because essentially you're saying
that like poor kids life's lives are
less valuable than rich kids no i don't
think so you know because
you're so sweet
no no i know you don't meet it that way
but like essentially you're saying if if
the kid's born into a poor family that
they should be aborted if they're so
poor that they leave it on the street is
what you're saying i mean someone if
they're born into a rich family they
shouldn't i mean say me now i wouldn't
be able to have a child because i know i
wouldn't be able to financially support
it yeah like it wouldn't grow up poor
but it wouldn't grow up the way i'd
wanted to grow up because i wouldn't be
able to give them everything i could
right
my financial status and you know yeah
but like i know it'd be supported by
just wouldn't think it's just the right
thing for them to grow up in i'd rather
them grow up in something
better
yeah so like maybe no abortion then like
i could have the child and give up for
adoption but like i'd rather just not
have her at all i was just about to ask
you that i was about to yeah because you
said how you for um abortion was the
only way out that's what you said right
and i was thinking maybe you could have
the child and just give up for adoption
that you think that would be more
suitable
yeah it would be multiple to be fair
yeah yeah yeah i was i always think of
it as like if the kid was there
at a certain age and you gave it the
option like would you rather die
or be given up for abortion i think
uh adoption sorry i think they would
always want the chance to have a
lifestyle you know i mean yeah and i
think anyone would
want the chance to have
life and the idea that we as humans are
taking life
at the point of conception is like
that's crazy because like imagine that
was you at a point of conception and
someone thought
yeah and i this this kid doesn't know
life
you're alive you never know though but
you're alive i'm alive to tell the story
but i never would have had a chance to
exist but this is what it is
we didn't exist though that's true but
what you're saying is fair in the
context of if there was an option to see
the laugh that you potentially would
have had versus not being born and then
have a decision but that's but you could
you could say the same thing about a
baby that's just been born because
they're not going to remember it you
don't have you don't have long-term
memory that that age
so you could say the same thing why not
just kill a baby outside the womb
because they won't remember it yeah i
hear it
i hear that that it's a fair argument
it's a fair argument
to be honest i hear um tegan's point
because it's something that me my sister
spoke about as well
um my only thing is that like
if if your worry is you know this is
just generally if your worry is that you
can't you may not be able to financially
take care of a baby raise it etc just
like
yo
don't have sex then do you know what i
mean it's not don't have sexists don't
have unprotected sex literally like
that's literally the logical answer like
oh as you say don't have unprotected sex
but then but then again like
contraception only works however many
percentage of the time
97
exactly so what about the upper feet
well it's higher than that if you get an
iud yeah yeah
yeah iud is the coil for the british
viewers
well and the crazy thing is the girls
that i know that got abortions um
they were just irresponsible
do you guys this is my next question do
you think that girls use abortion as a
form of birth control yes but
before i
could to the last question um i think
one thing that's important to the reason
i'm pro life i say it's probably
deliberating me i'm changing that you
realize pro-life is
anti-abortion see me and pray choices
the reason i said i was pro-choice um
it's probably the liberal in me um
provided this context because obviously
in some circumstances things happen to
women
that are unfortunate and a baby might be
the consequence of that which is
something i'm not the one that's gonna
have the baby i'm not ever gonna be
pregnant i'm never gonna know what it
feels like to be in that position right
so i think the only reason i was for
that option was the fact that
in certain contexts and so under certain
circumstances you might not want to have
that baby under those circumstances you
know what percentage of abortions that
is very low it is very low i know that
it's it's less than two percent but
again i have a sister so i imagine that
she was in that two percent i'd
understand if that was a decision i said
i think that's the only reason i'm for
that side yeah for every other reason
that as everyone's mentioned yeah it
only makes sense to have that child
right but yeah that's that's more of
like an exception it's something yeah
you're right you're right which which it
goes back to like do women use this as a
form of birth control they probably do
or do you think it's only
in extreme circumstances i'd say extreme
circumstances because there is a lot of
like
pregnancies isn't there like
that's not extreme
well i think something funny happens
when it becomes
my body my choice when it's now time to
take responsibility for another human
being
it's now time like okay it was fun you
know when we were laying there and we
were doing it
but now like oh [ __ ] do you know i mean
something's happening i'm allowed to
swear by the way right yeah okay
um you know i mean so i think i think
women um obviously do use it as a
scapegoat um
because and not to say like they're
they're like planning like some evil
vendetta like oh like let me just get
out of it but it's like oh [ __ ] life is
real that's like they're scared like
they're genuinely scared and i'm listen
i'm not surprised as a woman
i don't know what it's like but imagine
you know you're about to have a baby you
don't know what to do
next option oh i bought it you know
so um
going back to the
is it extreme circumstances or
do women use it as a form of birth
control 42 percent of women undergoing
abortions have had one or more previous
abortion
so from what okay i'm just getting this
context of that they're using it as
birth control
yeah and it's just a thing where i'm
just thinking right because
god forbid this happened but what if all
odd fails like you never know that the
condom could just fall off that iud
could just drop out like all of that
possibilities
could happen to the point where dorman's
like even if even if the man has
probably had a vasectomy yeah that's
baby's jesus
that's the rarest of the rarest
hail the
messiah
so you're saying what if you do
everything right and still get pregnant
yeah
that's when the child would i mean
that's when a woman would do an abortion
so but why are you sleeping with someone
that wouldn't be a good father
that's a good question why are you are
you sleeping with someone that's going
to bail for real
because
do you know if they're going to bail
though do you ever think this guy's like
no the guy's not serious right yeah yeah
some must have that character's life
i think most girls see the red flags and
we choose to ignore them yes i think
most girls like i how many girls do you
know that have gotten cheated on and go
back a million times
and are they thinking wow this is going
to be a great father to my children
no they're not thinking that no
and so my question is like why are you
sleeping with somebody
that
would be a bad father well the majority
of women to begin with will sleep with
the same men anyway correct so correct
so no but the thing is is like what why
i say a lot of women are naive to the
fact of how men behave so you know this
guy is bad for you in every inch because
women are quite perceptive you click
onto social cues quite simply
and you know for a fact this guy that's
inside me right now is not good for me
this is your chance to escape you don't
take it you purposely pursue this for
whatever reason
and then when the circumstances now flip
everybody starts to go crazy no but you
know what that is like shocked like oh
my god how did this happen listen you
knew you are going from there yeah
because the guy was
we hear it all the time bro the guy was
alpha he was so
he was so muscly he was so mysterious
and all that you know
that [ __ ] oh i want to change him i
want to change him classic
and then like all of a sudden oh why are
you why aren't you committing to me well
hello
the the signs were there
to begin with
i'm gonna have to actually agree with
you as well because it's a it's a point
where even paul was telling me like
majority i'm gonna use the girls in
london in it like let's not lie girls
let's not lie majority of you lost you
lost love of the alpha males and then
when he when he just runs away from you
you're there crying oh my gosh you ran
away from me no
we all knew we all knew that he was bad
for you you chose to sleep with him so
you put yourself in that position so i'm
not gonna for sympathy for you i really
won't 100 percent i really want so so
why do we feel sympathy for the girls
that get pregnant by him
you picked them for real don't you think
girls should kind of don't you think
girls should lay in the bed they made
common sense is not that common
yeah i always say this
men will conform to the standard that
women sit this new liberal movement of
we can do what men do and we're exactly
the same etc the introduction of
contraception and the freedom and the
proliferation of sex means that women
women can now make bad choices and all
these options to
to prevent these bad choices or these
social conventions means that they're
just completely making wrong options
taking the wrong option
if women set the standard that you know
men have to jump certain hoops in order
to to get to the point of um having sex
with you whether that's marriage
um or whatever it is men will follow
if you but women women change that
standard and now sex is now something
that's easily acquired so naturally the
neck the the the byproduct of that is
babies and childless child
and single parent homes and we know that
now that we create more single parent
homes the cycle then continues because
then kids grow up without the necessary
people in their lives the nuclear family
and they fall into the same the same the
same categories you often hear about oh
she has daddy issues well her daddy was
never there why because the mum made a
bad decision and society looked after
her when there wasn't supposed to
instead of administering the fear
that a baby should bring when you think
oh my god i'm going to have a baby so on
that don't you think that if abortion
was illegal maybe women would make
better decisions
yes yeah but i think what has happened
is that
the feminist movement has become quite
powerful so like the society is becoming
more gynocentric women don't want to
believe it but society is becoming more
female-led we still live in a patriarchy
but females have a very very powerful
voice in how they want things to be run
and in order for feminism to survive it
needs an enemy and part of what it does
is it tells people like the statistic i
quoted which is quite low that you know
what in the anomaly situation that let's
say grape happens i don't want to use
the word yeah and the consequence of
that is a baby
feminism will kind of push up the
numbers inflate the numbers to say look
this happens often but when you hit the
reality of the situation you realize
that that only happens a small fraction
of the time so really if it was illegal
it would be more beneficial well it's
like the one in um have you ever heard
the um statistic that one in five women
have been graped or sexually assaulted
yes
so
the reason it's so high isn't because
you know one in five women have actually
been graped or sexually assaulted it's
because they're including um girls that
had sex with somebody when they were
drunk so even if he was drunk too
they're still classify that as sexual
assault
yeah i thought that was a law that came
out that if even if the man was drunk
and he had sex with a drunk female
that's still grape it's not supposed to
be yeah that's what i was thinking
there's a book um by malcolm gladwell um
called talking to strangers and he he
makes the point of referencing um what
consent means
and he was making the point that you
know the legal system is not fair and it
is to some degree geared towards women
in that in that circumstance because
when they did the survey they found that
50 of men and 50 of women didn't know
what consent was so when two people are
drunk
um it would lean towards it being the
man's fault even though they're both
equally intoxicated yeah and if you if
you kind of push up those numbers then
actually you're gonna think that more
grape situations occur when they
actually don't so you know what's
interesting so if i get drunk and rob a
store am i absolved of accountability
not really because you're un you're
under the instruments of alcohol right
so you you're not in control of your
actions so you think if i went to a
judge after i robbed the store drunk do
you think they would say oh okay you
didn't slap on the wrist you didn't
actually want to do it i mean i don't
think it would happen like that but
i
let's take it one step further if i got
drunk and killed somebody
would i be absolved of accountability
definitely not if anything your friend
is looked at even worse you're locked up
yeah you're not controlling your actions
but what you still did was wrong type of
thing so you still get locked up but not
for a high
sentence whatever they do right so so
why is it that we can get drunk and have
sex and have no accountability for that
action well it is there's no rules
and i'm not talking about girls being
like passed out like clearly that's
that's a whole nother thing but just
being drunk
i don't think there's been any rules
really like established kind of like how
eddie was saying like there's not a um
you know concrete definition of what is
consent what is not etc but
a drunk driver all day we'll we'll lock
him up i don't know i don't think it's
that because i don't think you know i
think we know well enough what that
means the point is consent
as in um i don't think we need concrete
rules because we know morally what's
right and wrong so like you said if
someone's drunk and they kill someone
they looked at us even worse but when a
woman gets drunk and has sex oh my god
she's the victim so what this goes back
to is this idea of the gynocentric
society becoming more female-led meaning
that women often have the upper hand in
those situations because they don't have
to take responsibility for their actions
we both get drunk why am i why do i have
to be more responsible than you because
i'm a man when we're both intoxicated me
and her could be equally as drunk she
might climb onto me but if she wakes up
in the morning feeling a bit nasty for
what she did last night she can go to
the police and say look this happened i
was great
and she's observed of all responsibility
and there's there is a case that
happened in the u.s to two university
students where she she said it was great
later right and they pulled the footage
from the bar and she's literally pulling
him like i saw that she's pulling him in
to kiss her she's bringing like she's
pulling him back to the dorms
and if there wasn't footage he probably
would have went to jail and i think he
still got kicked out of university
and he wasn't allowed one of the most
recent ones was the girl that went to
was it iron apple where she had like a
fivesome and they recorded it um with
israeli guys i think
i think it was either five or twelve i
can't remember the number but then you
know she she probably woke up in the
morning and was like nah that's a
madness and she tried to call grape but
obviously the footage was there the
proof was there to show that
this was something that she wanted to do
and yet they went to the date they got
free but even then with those false
calls there's no repercussions for that
so a woman can fake cry grape
um and if she's found not guilty if the
guys found not guilty then like there's
no real repercussions for that either i
think that's also a problem i'm so sorry
i don't know if i actually imagined this
or not yeah but i genuinely thought that
there was going to be some sort of
repercussions for a lion or did i just
imagine that
i don't know but there's there might be
something coming yeah i wouldn't be
there
i really thought that i just imagined
that because i'm sure that i've read
somewhere where
it was
the male was more drunk than the female
i read somehow the female was more aware
of her surroundings but the men were the
ma the guy was just passed out so
obviously they've done what they've done
the morning comes the woman shouted out
grip and i was like huh so they must
have went to court but
i'm sure that the woman got a warning or
something but i just thought that
actually put something in place i feel
like something definitely needs to be in
place because
yes women have power and yeah i'm a
female as well by giving a female that
sort of power feel like that's dangerous
that you guys agree that is dangerous
we're getting there i mean amber had
just lost him
but she's still walking free she got
sued she's not in jail oh yeah i mean at
least she you know i mean she's still
got what two million imagine if the
girls were imagine if the roles were
reversed
he would be oh yeah he'd be dropped off
everything and locked up oh that case
would have been lost that would have
that would have ruined his career
the first accusations yeah
um apparently so um but yeah pirates of
the caribbean dropped him and obviously
they look kind of dumb now but anyway i
like proud of his caribbean man i really
like
uh so another so in the uk i've been
looking at more uk stats because i've
heard some complaints from you guys
where you said i don't reference enough
uk stats so
so i i am now okay so
98.1 percent of abortions which is 205
930 i believe that's per year
um are performed under group c so when
they survey people asking why they're
getting their abortions they say it's
because the pregnancy has not exceeded
its 24th week and that the continuation
of the pregnancy would involve risk
greater if the pregnancy was terminated
of injury to the physical or mental
health of the pregnant woman
behind keeping the law is not to protect
the baby but to protect the adult having
the baby so hold on wait i'm going to
get this straight in my head yes so they
put it under group c which is
i'm going to have an abortion because
the baby's going to cause me harm to my
mental health well yeah or your physical
yeah physical health as well i can't i
kind of agree because if you're not
strong enough to carry on for their
pregnancy like
i feel like well do you think maybe they
should have thought of that when they
were having sex of course of course
protected of course
this all goes back to individual
responsibility and i think that's that's
where it's going to continue to go
because regardless of the effects and
this is why i say um i would i've often
had the argument and and people often
tried like
and get angry at me for saying this but
i say that women have more
responsibility when if a man and woman
have sex women have more responsibility
to the kid than the man does because the
man can he can just disappear and you're
still left with the babies you're still
left with the physical aspects the
psychological aspects you get post-natal
depression etc etc etc all of the
kind of tangible responsibility falls on
you which means that you have more of an
impetus to make proper decisions about
who you lay with and and the
consequences of that but often that's
not the case well it's more of the
woman's fault than the guy if she got
pregnant because the contraception is
all from woman in there every day
so sorry about that but can't guys buy
condoms as well like does it just have
to be females
let me let me explain to you why i
believe this so so if as a female okay
if we want to not get pregnant we can go
get an iud yes then we can go get birth
control yeah on top of that i think
yeah cause guys have the option of
vasectomy as well
right right okay okay okay but then we
have the option to require that the men
that sleep with us wear condoms okay so
then if that doesn't work we can take a
plan b pill
if that doesn't work we can get an
abortion if that if we don't want to do
that we can give the baby up for
adoption
the man on the other hand
has the option to wear a condom and get
a vasectomy yeah a vasectomy it's
permanent it's not really an option yeah
and so so at the end of the day it's
really just condoms if the guy doesn't
want to risk getting a vasectomy
so and even if he does that what
happened with drake
a girl can still take the condom and try
to inseminate herself
remember the um sons as well the nba
team they got told to literally flush
their condoms down the toilet because
yeah yeah and so and that so on top of
that there's been cases where a woman
has given a kid up for adoption even
though the dad wants to keep it
yeah
that's a bit cruel yeah because if
the dad is willing to keep the child
then matt as well just leave the child
with the father if you don't want
nothing to do with the child that's fine
you've made your choice but at least you
know that someone is going to take up
their precious time to look after the
child because remember having kids is
it's not easy right but like what i so
what i always go back to on this show is
that
this is just another way that women
dodge accountability
it's where we're not we're always bailed
out with whatever bad decision that we
make and this is just another way that
they do it so if you choose not to use
the freaking
six seven did i list forms of birth
control yeah we can still get an
abortion and the men have no say
yes and let's remember like a basic
level
women are the gatekeepers of sex like
what did you say was two percent of yeah
actually get grapes right so yeah
the overall 98
of the time if you say to a guy that you
don't want to do it he's not going to
he's not going to do it that's what we
said you're literally the gatekeepers
women women control access to sex like
you're the gatekeepers of your yeah of
your walls so if you allow a man into
your walls then i arguably be prepared
for the consequences that follow
but again as as pearl mentioned society
is is is so female-led that there's so
many different options for a woman to
get out of a situation of having to take
accountability for our own actions and
that's not fair because obviously often
we'll hear
and this is this is the this is the
downplay to the mass of men is that you
know the patriarchy do this misogyny
that and they did but women don't
actually realize how much power they
actually have
a lot of power well women make make 70
to 80 of consumer buying decisions so
everything in the media is marketed
towards women
a lot of decisions you see policy wise
are for the female vote
100
which i'm all for giving back i'll take
one for the team
[Laughter]
okay um so let me
let me read some super chats real quick
guys if you want to see what ish looks
like i know it's it's a mystery everyone
wants to know what does ish look like
send super chats because we're trying to
get him a camera
i really want a camera guy so
trust me i look good looking what is
that what is that hashtag hashtag
yeah
get issue camera makes sense you won't
be disappointed trust me
[Laughter]
he's looking at me right now
okay never die
um okay we got five dollars from real
thumb sapien
yeah
um okay mark mark perdue name one
medical issue where abortion is the
abortion is the cure a c-section works
just fine um ryda that is the dumbest
statement dragon stallion one zero zero
one uh i'm gonna read that question last
because i think that's actually a good
question um tough rabzi raspy there are
over 40 contraceptions but you sadly but
you get sadly lazy as hell about it for
being smart with sex mark perude if you
can't afford a baby that means you can't
afford to have sex be responsible it's
called accountability i agree um janice
per gal
um just a little sticker thank you um
oh ryder okay abortion is the epitome of
female unaccountability um
please read for economics it discusses
incentives and how and outcomes chapter
4 establi establishes a casual link
between legalized abortion and lower
rates of crime um to the moon in the 90
in the us 90 of abortions are elective
michael wesley too the soul enters the
fetus on the 121st day abortion after
that could be considered murder abortion
before that okay this is according to
some islamic test texts primary question
when does the soul enter the fetus james
espinosa hey pearl please study the
history of social feminism has always
been gender socialism it is designed
specifically to subvert and destroy the
west to the moon a man's reputation can
be ruined ruined over a a rumor a
woman's is protected let me just refresh
to make sure there weren't any more that
i missed
today
okay um donovan's saint claire
uh a sticker thank you and then i'm
gonna read this question
question for the panel if they are
pro-choice are they pro-death penalty
for criminals
um if you
hold this if you don't hold this ethic
then why is it okay to kill a baby and
not a criminal
so you guys pro death penalty
good question good question
yeah my pro death penalty
shout out to you man i mean i think a
lot of people would say it depends on
the crime right because it's like let's
be honest if you steal a pack of crisps
from your local corner shop and someone
rats you out you're going to say yo chop
that guy's head off
obviously this is contextual yeah but
for me like honestly if there was a way
to 110
with no deviation
until someone done a crime and and this
is the most egregious crimes against
humanity like
just i don't know like mass grape or
stuff along those lines and you know
without a shadow of a doubt that that
person did it i don't care kill that
[ __ ] that is what it is
so i'm for that but again my stance on
the abortion issue
only relates to that two percent other
than that i don't like
i'm pro-life all the way do you know i
have a quick question freddie
because you said you have a sister i got
two sisters i've got two sisters here as
well by the way
do you think if we didn't have sisters
we like would you still
be would you still have that similar
mindset or is it because is it because
like
okay
like i
men we have to protect women yeah i'm
just no i'm just asking that and i don't
understand that we have to protect women
that's it that's just part of our
responsibility as men
so obviously having sisters helps like
i've grown up with them and obviously
i'm someone that likes to read and learn
so i see what happens out there i see
what sort of crimes benny can commit
which is why it's our responsibility to
help women but
yeah i think my my viewpoint
it should be consistent with it because
women are women regardless whether i
have a sister or not
so what about you guys death penalty yes
or no
it depends on the crime yeah so you'd
say yes because essentially you think
some crimes yeah
you know i'll be real i'll say
again this is kind of from my religious
background but
i
i would say yes i am
and also annoy because i'll be
it sounds it sounds corny but it's like
i
who am i to basically decide whether
someone should live or die you know i
mean to me like only god has that you
know god has that prerogative yeah
when i think about people that touch
kids exactly
and this is what i mean i personally if
it was me i'd be like yeah like stone
him chop him down like whatever but like
i guess the religious side of me would
be like
i think you also have to take into
account as well that
it depends on whether i'm the one making
that decision or not i'm happy to speak
as someone who can speculate as to
whether that's right or wrong but if i
was the person that says oh i'm don't
have to push the button to administer
that death i probably would have a
different outlook on it
i'm not the one committing that i'm not
the one murdering this person for
whatever crime that they committed so
it's easy to have that standpoint of
someone who's not going to actually push
the button or because so probably even
tougher question like could i do it if
that person was of those crowns
whenever you're in the shoes really so
it's like when you go back to abortion
it only depends when you're in those
shoes
when it's you
it's it's okay to a standpoint and like
think of something like someone else's
shoes but and it's you it's different in
it so i'm probably so myself i'm
pro-life and i look at that question
when you talk about as a criminal like
should they be
prosecuted by death penalty penalty if
like their crime is so egregious and i'm
like
my stance is on the religious basis who
am i
to take life when i didn't give it
do you know what i mean so when i hear
like everyone like
well in this case it's okay in this case
it's not we're all looking at how we
emotionally feel about a certain
situation and i think when you put
emotions into a playwright
someone's emotions could be in higher
regard than the next person's does it
make it right
which is why you have to be 100 sure
because
even if you're 100 sure if i'm 100 sure
that this person stole
a million pounds
like a million pounds to someone else
might be like
life-changing
to who the worst of the so what so
touching kids isn't universally
egregious i'm not saying it isn't i'm
just saying
taking life is one thing yeah yeah okay
i understand but see the way i look at
it is incentives
and as a society when you when you up
the punishment for something less people
do it true
so what
oh come on i agree i agree
more so than anything i'm like the
people take
committing these egregious crimes i
think there's a certain level of mindset
that they've been through or a level of
trauma that they've gone through that
has put them in a place where they're
going to commit that crime at some point
i some right some but
i think there's a group that would be a
bit scared if they knew that was the
punishment
and to me that would be saving children
because the majority of kids that get
sexually abused go on to do the same
thing
so i just have a special hatred in my
heart
for people that touch kids i think
that's disgusting
do you think they deserve the death
penalty oh yeah okay that them
yeah like i think that's the worst crime
you could possibly do this i agreed do
you think imagine a powerful question do
you think mattresses does have the death
penalty as well
yeah i'd say no to that yeah i think i
think it really
like the serial killers that sort of
thing
yeah
but what about if you take someone's
life yeah that's content they're gonna
ask no
no context you've taken someone's life
yeah
if it's is it intentional
well no no some people do it in
self-defense yeah so like that would be
called man's law but like i'm saying
take taken someone's life it was
intentional let's say um someone
um
cheated with your
it was in an act of love like someone
cheated on you with cheating's different
from men in front of you
but then
let's
[Laughter]
yeah but like let's say
they deserve the death penalty like if i
did that yeah i would deserve the death
penalty because what my emotions made me
commit murder someone take someone's
life away from their family
that's horrible that's a horrible thing
to do 100 sure i agree but death penalty
i don't know the thing is i don't think
these things can be seen as like dick
they cut they're not like cutthroat
they're not cutthroat you can't see them
as universal things i think when it
comes to these because humans are just
so different there has to be context you
can't have a one-size-fits-all because
again
something like murder yeah we can all
agree that murder is wrong and we can
all agree that you know no human should
hold the power to decide on whether
someone should be killed or or or die
but we have context you know someone
might try to do something to your mother
your sister a family member your best
friend and to defend them you have to
potentially take the person's life or if
you didn't deal with the consequences of
not having been able to act upon that
situation so with context it's not going
to be a one-size-fits-all and again with
these conversations it's not a
one-size-fits-all thing either
true no
um you know it's another interesting
stat so 50 of women over 30 are single
and childless it'd be really interesting
to see what percentage of them have had
abortions
do you know the number that would be i
don't know i wish i did i couldn't find
it
it would be better if you did that
but based based on the numbers you've
caught before i think would say those
was 97 or 98 of women who have have had
abortions have had it more than no 42 42
have had it before i've had it before
so
that is quite a high number
yeah so given that
you could imagine that these women
in their 30s they have been sexually
active yeah so you can imagine that in
in those situations mistakes would have
happened right well and you'd also think
about
because the other half that's their
first abortion but will they come back
in the future so it's really i don't
know what the percentage would be if you
include like if we re-surveyed the same
group of women but i don't think they
they gather data like that yeah but i'll
be crazy to find out though yeah
because they really
like again every girl that i know that's
had an abortion personally like they
were just irresponsible they weren't on
any form of birth control they're
sleeping with a guy they couldn't see a
future with
and then
it's it's the role of tomasi says it's
the ultimate form of hypergamy shout out
to the goat
why do women do that they're like no i'm
not saying all women do that let me take
that back but then it's like why do some
woman sleep it goes back to the question
of why are some women sleeping with guys
that they don't see a future with like
that came back to what you said before
earlier guys
guys are out here ignoring the red flags
like why are you ignoring the red flags
you're doing this to yourself type of
thing and then when it comes to the
point of going back to today's topic
abortion i couldn't afford sympathy for
you because you put yourself in that
position so i think this time
i think this starts it begins with the
family and the the nuclear family has
been under decrease for for years now
so as you can see as the family starts
to break apart like to give an example
the reason why
um
a woman a guy would have to ask for um a
father to marry his daughter is because
that guy would of the father would often
check is this man worthy of my daughter
does he have the right characteristics
of a man
but this
idea of oh i'm independent i can do it
alone i don't need a man men or trust
etc etc just reinforces this these
negative
aspects because i think women are quite
naive like you don't understand men to
the capacity that other men can
understand men and i also say that men
understand women then other women
understand themselves why because men
have to pursue women so we have to
understand how you behave in order to
successfully court and date and get
women so with that when you have
brothers and men in your life
and you ask them questions they will
give you objective answers to help you
understand the situation that you're in
so like my sisters for example they'd
often come to me and say that you know
this boy is making me feel this way like
what's going on and i can explain that
to them and i'm sure that that's helped
them out of countless
unnecessary situations it really does
like i i started telling my dad about
the guys i'd like go on dates with or
whatever and i like i would just give
him stories and let's just explain them
to him and like guys are so perceptive
and they just understand men quicker
than we can 100 percent but it only
helps if they listen though in it that's
the thing like that and that's the thing
until you actually like listen to what a
guy is saying and i've realized in my
only experience anyway like i think the
only women that actually understand men
are women that have had like maybe or
more brothers
or like you did you see what i'm saying
because it's like if you're forced to be
if you're forced to grow up with someone
like i i got two sisters you got two
sisters right and at one point i i was
living with my two sisters and my mom so
i got three women in the house so
i have no choice but to almost
understand women because it's like why
is she getting emotional why is she like
this what did she do so i got i got to
force myself no it's interesting you say
that because i always say i can tell the
difference a lot of times between girls
that grew up with brothers and group of
sisters
what do you think the difference is
it's um i've just noticed girls that
grow up with brothers often are like
more tomboy less drama a bit more
switched on to certain situations yeah
people are aware
yeah
yeah i mean i'm not not always i'm not
saying i get it 100 of the time but
um and then it's interesting you say
that because i grew up with five
brothers
so it's like
your family's like a foot what's your
name
it's a bunch of tall gingers
so another thing so um in 2017 northern
ireland
funding scheme introduced to provide
funded abortions in england wales and
wales for residents of northern ireland
in cases of hardships travel costs are
also covered funding is provided by the
government equalities office and hm
treasury
do you guys think that we should be
publicly funding abortions no no no
publicly yeah that's that's just like
the easy way out i know they see that
they're like oh it's free anyways let's
just go yeah my travels covered
it's covered this is interesting because
you're pro-choice and you still agree
that it shouldn't be publicly funded it
shouldn't be
my my answers are changing now like as
i'm getting educated
but like
yeah no it should not be publicly funded
no i agree because like why do i have to
pay for her bad yeah
i have to pay for that no it's not what
paul was telling me exactly what paul
was telling me earlier like
you decided to sleep in bed at 2 a.m in
the morning with this guy why am i now
paying for what you decided to do me i
was sleeping at 2 a.m you you decided to
go be with me look what i put you look
at it for me i've got good night's rest
you're there panicking about your future
that's the difference
like
so why do me and you are not the same
i'm sleeping
i'm sleeping and you're there panicking
oh my gosh i'm pregnant without dude no
take it back two weeks ago what was you
doing at 2am in the morning exactly so
you got yourself to fend for that and on
the topic of
should it be publicly funded no we
shouldn't because once you give
something free free free to the public
they're abusive
so
it's interesting because i was looking
at the numbers so abortion numbers
england and wales from 2010 to 2020. um
ish can you pull up the it's the
second
no it's the first link in the google doc
um and if you scroll down go to
figure 2.1
go down scroll down yeah scroll down it
should
two key points in 2020.
do you see that yeah so when
nhs made abortions publicly funded you
see in 2016 it was 190 000 abortions per
year it's
that like 220 215 thousand so you see
how that's just abused isn't it like
yeah
so that's like specifically when they
made it publicly funded that skyrocketed
so 2016 they made it publicly funded
yeah okay you can see the skyrocketing
yeah 2017. i forgot what i said that's
the kind of thing that makes you start
thinking conspiracies are real in terms
of population control
this is okay this is what we're gonna
this next part okay
so
in and this is the next part that i was
gonna talk about so in the u.s one of
the number one abortion providers is do
you guys know what it is is it the
government planned parenthood oh wow
so planned parenthood it's one of the
number one abortion providers in the u.s
and
i wish i had an american on the panel
because they would know how big planned
parenthood is like there's a really big
fight on whether the government should
be able to fund planned parenthood
because planned parenthood is the number
one abortion provider in the u.s
so um
margaret sanger was the one who
founded planned parenthood in the early
like
actually i don't know when it was i
think the early 1900s but she was a
eugenicist
okay so she believed like that whites
were the inferior race
inferior
oh wait superior sorry sorry
she believed that whites were the
superior race
and
basically the black population in the us
would be double today if it weren't for
planned parenthood because the planned
parenthood disproportionately provides
abortions to the black community so much
so that there
it's almost 50 percent of black births
are aborted it's 474 per 1000
live births and 80 even to this day 80
of planned parenthoods are in minority
neighborhoods
and there's no outcry
i'm i'm not surprised by that statistic
to be honest
i'm not surprised i agree and the
statistics are just there like we can't
argue with that so i'm gonna i'm gonna
read um an excerpt from it's like two
paragraphs but when it they talked
about i can't remember the name of the
document i got this from but margaret
singer a founder of the american birth
control movement was a leading
spokesperson an activist in pro
in promotion of controlling the birth
rates among blacks and others she
considered genetically inferior an avid
supporter of eugenics saenger became a
formidable force when pushing her
project designed to employ black leaders
to promote first birth control and later
abortion as viable options for family
planning she favor she
favored the mal illusion branch of
eugenics frequently saying the genetic
makeup
or of poor and minorities for example
was inferior sanger believed that it was
necessary to reduce the birth rate among
the diseased the sickly the poverty
stricken and the anti-social classes
elements unable to provide carrying for
themselves and the burden of which we're
all forced to carry paying black staff
members into the six figures planned
parenthood and other abortion supporters
have banned their advocates across the
black community spouting a deceptive yet
unified message of the lack of access to
quality healthcare supported by funds
provided through such foundations as as
those headed
by the fords the rockefellers the
carnegies the gates the soros and others
pro-abortion forces deliberately craft
messages that play on the fears of some
blacks that a lack of access to abortion
is somehow discriminatory discriminatory
then and now sanger's organization has
used trusted leaders to convince the
black community that abortion as a form
of birth control is not only acceptable
but also beneficial to the afro
african-american culture
wow i agree because the whole agenda
yeah but i agree on the i agree to an
extent to the point where it's kind of
like you're trying to help
the um the minority and if the minority
grew up in a poverty do you say poverty
state yeah yeah if you're trying to help
the minority that grew up in a poverty
state why are you going to argue with
that it really does make sense because
you can't you're in a pub you're in a
poverty state like you're not going to
be able to provide for the child you're
not going to be able to
let them live a happy life you know
they're just going to go upstairs
when they're not trying okay one what
you think that poor kids are more
depressed than rich kids
just automatically off the bat i know
some of them are not not all but
sometimes yeah
i wouldn't even i'd say like
rich kids are more depressed than poor
kids
actually i think oliver james in a book
called affluenza makes the quote and he
says that people i think even per capita
in terms of happiness
north korea had more happy people than
people in the west
but and here's and here's the thing like
the argument you're making and i know
you're not doing this intentionally it's
the same argument that sanger was making
with eugenics she believed that poor
people were less valuable
and so a lot of the uh they didn't mean
that no no no it's so it's okay i know
it's
okay but it's like
the
the arguments that i hear people that
are pro-choice make are the same
arguments that margaret sanger a
eugenicist made
and it's it's sad because i think it's
so brainwashed into the culture
i mean i think that's right because
these people aren't stupid they're
intelligent people
so
i think you need 2.5 babies in order to
prevent to to um
to continue our culture so in order for
let's say italians to continue living on
those italians they need to have 2.5
babies per family in order for that
culture to continue
for a long time now they've known that
you know a lot of the um certain ethnic
groups why it's been one of them
babies are on the decrease yeah so in
order to control that and keep the white
race alive
these kind of attitudes have been pushed
to say you know what in order to prevent
the white race from being wiped out
essentially we need to decrease the
amount of babies being born by other
ethnic groups and try to increase the
babies being born by white groups if you
look at africa i think in a i feel like
i did an essay on this in nigeria in the
next 10 to 20 years will have one of the
most the biggest populace of of people
in the world china you know really had
that um a massive population of people
and
these people venture out and then they
migrate and then they breed with the
local communities and that kind of
pushes people out
so in order to control um the the
demographic then these are some of the
things that be pushed so it's i don't
think it's a conspiracy this is factual
this is it's written down it's
documented but again the way it's sold
to people is that it's actually
beneficial for the community now that
you said it like that you actually
understand like now that you study like
that i get it properly now well and it's
it's interesting because imagine like
they were tearing down statues in the
u.s because they said that the found
like certain founders were racist right
fair enough but why isn't there an
outcry that this woman wanted to control
the black population and she
successfully is and did it
very should be but again indeed in the
poor communities one of the things that
they lack is proper education
um so yeah resources their resources
their ability to to gain certain
knowledge and again when it's been sold
to them that it's beneficial as well and
then you look at the black community in
america or anyway and a lot of these lot
attacks you look at some of our role
models
and naturally you're going to think that
you know
finesse mandem and shake bambam on
camera
but that's what you should be doing so
our role models
aren't correct evo so naturally these
aren't going to be conversations being
pushed by by leaders in the black
community especially over there yeah
um i saw an interesting question in the
super chats
um there's like interracial dating i'm
saying to do that as well like the whole
um
like obviously you know lifting the
superior like white race and you know
any like college race especially black
people because obviously nowadays you
don't see a lot of black like black
relationships going on
what can you talk about
yeah there's i'm asking you something
they wouldn't want interracial they
ended one they wouldn't they wouldn't
want it no well the majority of um
like black people date other black
people in the u.s at least it's like 85
yeah okay so i guess it wouldn't really
then i mean i would think that a
eugenicist would not want that to happen
no yeah which is kind of interesting
because when people talk about
interracial dating like it's always
black and white they never think about
india and south america yeah asian mix
like india yeah india and white
or asian i just think in recent history
like whites and blacks have been so
closely interconnected
that naturally like as
although we see many differences in us
there's probably a lot of similarities
as well
so
um so and i think some of you maybe have
asked answered this question before but
if the women
are able to get an abortion do you think
men should be able to have a financial
abortion 100
yes
yes
yes
yeah sorry
sorry about that i'm going to go yes why
because if you get a say like it's like
what me and you were talking about
earlier if i get well say but it's
potentially me actually no no i don't
want to use me because i wouldn't do
this realistically realistically it's
just a woman
saying she wants to get rid of the child
and it's like
she can't
but and then
she's looking for the person who she
intertwined with
no like why are you asking him type of
thing right well it should be about
equality right yeah if we get the option
to not be a mother why don't they get
the option to not be a father yeah
big correct so if i can't tell you
if i don't have a decision telling you
to keep the baby
and i don't have a decision telling you
not to keep the baby then naturally um
you shouldn't have your decision or
about your money about my money or where
it goes 100. because i see money as more
more than money like you know money you
can get back what time you can't i spend
time making that money and i have to
give that time something that's not
finite to you i'm sorry that's fine that
to you for something that i didn't want
it doesn't make no sense it doesn't make
no sense cool it takes two to tango and
i understand that but i maintain that
when we don't have equal responsibility
yeah when it comes to a baby
a lot of the responsibility for
responsibility falls on the woman
therefore you should make better
decisions who you lie with and in the
event that a baby does come and this
wasn't something that you wanted then it
is what it is what it is you can't you
can't have my money as a consequence of
that yeah
are you guys aware of how abortions are
like how someone gets an abortion i
think the doctor just takes some plies
now to pull stuff out doesn't it isn't
there there's a couple different ways i
know that there's the
sorry what did you say they like break
the baby apart yeah yeah that's what i
was going to say and then
for some you can take a pill
so i'm not too sure early on yeah right
it's not early on
like if i feel like i don't know i'm not
too correct maybe paul might know this
but if it's like three weeks four weeks
maybe you can take a pull button then if
the baby has progressed to like a couple
months maybe someone can get them no the
doctors can get their pliers and then if
it goes into the six mark point i feel
like is a cesarean would be needed type
of thing
so yeah so the first option is there's a
pill and i think that's up to 12 weeks
so that essentially starves the baby of
nutrients
and so like they take the pill and
within a couple days they like bleed or
whatever
but no you're correct they actually um
the other type of abortion is after 12
weeks they pull the baby out limb by
limb
and then crush its head and pull it out
and i have okay
so
the fun fun links guys
you're actually watching this no no it's
not no it's not a video so it's a
picture
no um go to the
second link in the google doc
so i think i remember watching an
american doctor
talk about some of the psychological
damage he has
having
done so many abortions i'm not surprised
yeah so i'm gonna i'm gonna read this um
you wanna pull it up um yeah you see the
picture the picture the three yeah zoom
in can you zoom in on there
if you can zoom in
i'm going to show it to them over here
too
just give me one second let me let me um
get it for the people at home okay
guarantee
very cool
okay so
uh a sp
a speculum is placed in the vagina and a
tan tana column is clamped onto the lip
of the cervix and a cannula is inserted
into the uterus
then step two the anamonic fluid
placenta and fetus are suctioned through
the cannula into the collection jar this
is the fetus and the placenta are torn
apart in the process and then see the
uterine cavity is scraped with a
curette to determine whether there are
any significant amount of tissues
remaining so suction abortion also
called vacuum aspiration is the most
common abortion procedure in the world
it falls under the broader banner of
dilation and
curetage which can be performed with a
sharp curette suction cure reddish which
was first used in russia in 1927. 37 30
years later the technique was perfected
in china and today the national abortion
federation reports that virtually all
modern first trimester surgical
abortions are accompanied by vacuum
asper aspiration and roughly in 2015
roughly 73 of abortions were performed
surgically and 86 of these were
performed at or before the 13-week
gas stration
um okay so i'm going to show you guys
the picture
of this
so for everyone at home the pictures
that we are showing you right now is the
ones that
pearl will be showing try not try not to
click the x okay
not not you sorry
i think i've watched one of those
you need to pull it back up
as soon as she said don't do it
i don't even know how that happened i'm
so sorry
can you like hold her up for us instead
i guess yeah that's what i was thinking
yeah i was gonna say just hold it let
don't even let me touch it i was gonna
hold it for us anyways
hold on let me pull it up over here you
can yeah they should be able to see it
from where you are
um okay yeah you're right i like all the
laptops touchscreen though i really like
it clearly not because you don't keep
texting
okay
um i mean
okay
eddie you made a good point earlier i
haven't forgotten it i'm gonna tell you
they're like pulling the limbs out and
then they crush the head and pull it out
and then they vacuum the rest
and it's it's crazy because i didn't
actually pull this video i couldn't find
the video before i was a little rushed
today thankfully
but but it's crazy because if you look
at like the
the videos of an abortion happening and
you see the baby like squirming away
moving yeah moving away from it
yeah you see the baby like moving away
oh my goodness yeah i mean i don't know
and i don't know how far along this this
video that i saw was but i was scarred
like it was so gross and then that shows
that the baby already had that already
shows that the baby has an instinct of
pro survival in the like already has a
natural instinct from the room
for the fact that it's moving away yeah
from the
vacuum yeah i'm not too sure but from
the tool
it's already moving
and then i saw a video that had
someone that worked in an abortion
clinic and she said some abortions like
the baby where a baby was like
taken out alive basically like it was
still alive when it came out because it
was a late abortion
and they wouldn't save it
because
yeah
no that's actually really upset and not
be cereal
we just gotta make better decisions man
for real yeah we've gotta change
humanity for the bar you really have to
that's literally where it starts
literally starts from decision making
yeah yes
starts from guys being smart guys guys
we knew what she meant she flopped
everyone got this yeah
[Laughter]
oh no no what you were saying earlier
about how like everything nowadays is so
like geared towards women and everything
um i think just like for the guys out
there watching i think the best way for
us as guys to kind of
like
combat against that is to stand firm in
our masculinity proud you know healthy
masculinity positive masculinity you
know shout out to the goat roller
tomassie if you've read his book you
know what he talks about is you know we
exactly we have to be
in a sense we have to be okay with the
ridicule because we will get as you said
you know earlier you've had experiences
in real life where people oh you're oh
you're a misogynist oh you're you're
this
when you've literally just offered a
logical rebuttal to what is going on
is calling up bad behavior yeah i'm
behaving poorly that i'd like to know as
well so yeah exactly i'm seeing the
effects and the repercussions in society
of how you know if people behave in a
certain way with impunity then that
you're gonna push the limits and i feel
like we're getting to a stage where as
as soon as a man opens his mouth to
discuss a woman anything to do what
women do oh yeah you're ripped to shred
straight away even on tick tock you know
one girl was saying why is it that on
every podcast you know men are always
talking about women that's it well
it's only two of us here it's a topic of
conversation that needs to be had so
let's discuss and talk about it yes
men with mics that's what they always be
saying men use podcasters therapy to
talk a little bit yeah yeah we have
educated conversations we quote stats
and figures and articles that we read in
order to learn and come to conclusions
about what we think
i'm not going to sit here and take your
opinion as fact because the truth is not
relative yeah you know the truth is
objective and this is what we're doing
we're telling the truth
so i'm curious from the ladies do you
think men should have a say in abortion
or do you think it's my will my opinion
or my body my choice sorry no they
should because if they think that they
want to keep the child then they should
be able to like
and she's just not about it really so
you think if
if i want to get an abortion and the
person i'm say dating doesn't want me to
he should be able to veto it
it's a tricky one but like going back to
what you said earlier in it like if they
want the child like why should you take
their life away
if someone is willing to bring that
child up in a happy environment why
should you get rid of that yeah it's
quite selfish isn't it yeah yeah yeah
no i i agree with you i'm just surprised
it seems like your opinion flipped a
little oh yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm kind
of educated guys yeah
okay i'm gonna read some super chats um
okay i'm gonna start from the top
the zap a great show pearl but if the
death penalty deterrence was effective
the usa would have a lower murder rate
than canada with no death penalty that's
actually a good point um william the
point i made is that it's funny to me
that scientists say they find life on
other planets when they're literally
talking about frozen microbes yet we
can't figure out when life begins in
children oh that's a good that's a good
that's so good why that's a good thing
yes sir
pgop but what about the abortions that
weren't reported before it was publicly
funded i think abortions will happen
regardless if it's free or not i think
having it free just adds us a safer way
to do it
dude what do you guys think about that
so having it free is a safer way to do
it well it's going to happen anyway so
you might do it for free because
it's it well damage like you're talking
to that oh sorry that's damage if you
think about it because if you're
so you're talking about free to the
public right or is it just free in
general free in general
okay
come back to me if if you're so
driven to have the abortion that you do
it yourself
do what you've got to do type things
like if you're going to do that by
yourself crazy but we what we're trying
to do there's two separate conversations
here like
when it's free people abuse that it
becomes a service that people can use
willingly and freely i agree and that
that's where you draw the line if you if
you if you're so desperate after
abortion you have your reasons i don't
know what the answer to that is but
having it be free no because again it
gives people the opportunity to to make
mistakes that shouldn't be made
yeah yeah i was going to say that as
well because you could also say
people are people are going to
actually i was going to say people are
going to murder anyway so why don't we
just not take away the penalty yeah but
i don't think that's a really good
argument to be honest because i was
thinking it's not free no but it's yeah
it's yeah i get what you're trying to
say but just because you know that
people are going to do it anyway like
people are going to steal anyway so
should we just not have any lawyers
right of course we should we should
always try to deter things that
have negative impacts on society whether
or not people are going to do it i have
no control but at least there's there's
processes in place to prevent these
negative things from happening
um okay so another super chat is i don't
know if the panel knows about the black
woman youtuber who went on a rant
telling black women to abort black men's
babies while being the mother of a black
man herself they hate black men that
much in the u.s
james espinosa the conspiracy is real
feminism is gender socialism the
socialists have spent over 100 years
infiltrating our cultures we are in the
cold war crazy guy women can abort a
child should oh that's the same one as
earlier let me just refresh it because i
think i saw one more
okay
free free isn't free it's the tax
taxpayers who pay for it even those who
disagree with it government coercion i
actually agree with that because we all
agreed that we don't think it should be
publicly funded yes it really shouldn't
um and then it's just selfish that
people think it's okay to do
okay so let's say let's say
end of the show everyone's pro-life okay
okay i don't know how you cannot be with
these reasoning skills
i'm not going to pat myself on the back
okay okay do you think women should be
tried if they have an abortion
sorry so let's say abortion's illegal
okay
and it's 2022 they said you know what
this is barbaric let's make it illegal
and a girl goes out and gets an abortion
anyway if we believe that abortion
begins at life that's a child so that's
murder
should we try the women that get
abortions 110 because at that point
based on the law it is murder so
therefore you've committed that crime
and you should be tried um justly for
that if you did the crime you've got to
do the time
i don't know i'm really like iffy about
that one because like
murder has always been illegal
so
but abortion never hasn't always been
illegal so it would only be going
forward because at least in the us you
can't try someone for a crime if it
wasn't a crime at the time
so it would be like moving forward if a
girl chooses to get an abortion
yeah yeah yeah i guess yeah yeah
actually quickly going back here but why
did she choose to because then obviously
there's circumstances such as group
such as grip yeah i'm just going to use
great but the thing is we're saying
tried we're not saying like she's going
to get like so she she has a chance to
like make her case okay
you know given the if that was the
lawyer she should be tried okay then
yeah yeah well even with grape like i
think if it's
it's either a baby or it's not a baby if
it's a baby there's no i i'm sorry it's
a horrible situation yeah but
if if you genuinely believe it's a child
then that's murder yeah yeah it's still
murder
and the argument like
and i think a lot of conservatives will
say okay we'll give them great because
98 of abortions aren't
so i think because that's always the
emotional appeal that liberals tend to
do is though as they'll use the extreme
in order to justify all of it
so um
yeah so we agree on that if they should
be tried i think everyone said yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
okay wow this is like the most i've
never had a panel where everyone never
agrees yeah yeah
i'll be the calmest
[Laughter]
because i was like everyone not even one
person disagree
nah full of i feel like we all got in
there yeah you know what though i think
we came into the conversation with
slightly different opinions yeah and
they all kind of merged as the
conversation went because you can't deny
the facts and i think
to the for someone to disagree with just
to be
out of pure ignorance because again
we've laid out the facts
we've articulated in a way that's
understandable so for you to go against
what we're saying it's like you're just
crazy at this point
but there's people like that because
obviously there's a whole oh no i've
told these facts i've had an abortion
show before yeah yeah okay it went very
differently yeah there's a lot of crazy
people out there that you know don't
ignore the facts for the for like the
two percent right and we always maintain
that the exception to the rule doesn't
make the rule therefore we're not going
to live by exceptions
well and it's interesting because when
you literally hear the pro-choice
arguments it's always it's always
they're they're too poor so then
you're putting their value at less yeah
and but that's again that comes from a
place of ignorance because right places
like africa and i do believe that you
know children are a consequence of of
poor situations right um because that
tends to happen you know you have poor
and you know less educated people who
come together and kids will be a
consequence of that
but that doesn't make anybody your life
is all equal you know that doesn't make
your life worse or less plus
people come out of these situations and
make something of themselves and that's
often the story you know from from rags
to riches so if you to
stop that
there's zero logic to understand how
someone could be against or can make
that case it makes zero sense well and
it's interesting because um like my mom
was in i don't know i think some of you
may have heard this story before but my
mom got pregnant when she was 17 by my
dad and they ended up giving that kid up
for adoption
and he ended up like growing up and he
he's really successful now he he's just
got married he's i think he has a baby
on the
yeah greg's having a baby
congratulations
congratulations yeah but they gave him
up for adoption and like they ended up
getting married later and having nine
more kids
and then adopting three other kids later
and so when i saw that i realized that
you can get pregnant and be in a bad
situation and still come out on top
and do more because now she's adopted
three kids that right essentially could
have had and now they've all gonna have
good lives yeah so and we also got
reunited with greg later i was just
about to ask that yeah yeah i know no he
um
yeah we like hang out with him now i
found i didn't know he existed until i
was 21. it was kind of weird but
so i could see from that that
even if something bad happens something
great can still come out of it but a lot
of women they think their lives are over
if they have a kid when it could be the
best thing that's ever happened to you
yeah yeah you never actually know you
know that is true
like
it all depends on your scenario in your
living scenario at the end of the day
but i i heavily agree with you well and
how often have you heard about
grandparents that got married through
shotgun weddings
people used to have unplanned
pregnancies they just get married after
oh wow
i'm not saying it's common in my culture
but
it's
known i don't want to say i'd only use
the word common but it is known for that
to happen just so that when the child is
born they can say that the child is born
through wedlock
yeah in nigeria that's i think this is
still practice to this day if you get
the girl pregnant you better marry that
woman because the other family's not
going to have none of it
you got my daughter pregnant you're
marrying my daughter within that nine
months yet me yeah
it is what it is and
in honesty
this is why
i think growing up i was more of a
liberal
but now i'm teetering towards the i'm
becoming a black conservative
i'm starting to see that a lot of these
these these liberal ideologies create
more problems in their solving society
this willingly unstructured way of
living is not conducive to a successful
life
and we'll start to see the consequences
of that the liberals are amassing way
too much power and and there's a lot of
problems that's happening in society as
a consequence of that because
humans need structure we live by
structures
everywhere you look there's a structure
and liberals are destroying that
structure
and nothing's coming to replace it but
what replaces structures anarchy and
we're going into a state of anarchy now
when did you become conservative
ah do you know what i think probably
today right here today right here you
know what it is i've always had
conservative conservative ideals but i
felt like i felt like my more my liberal
ideals outweighed my conservative ones
because going to university i did
international relations i studied a lot
of political theory and stuff like that
um i i studied a lot to do with like um
psychology and help and to understand
how people's minds work and i think
coming from a poor background it's easy
to fall into that liberal mindset you
know that you know things happen to me
and because i'm black and you know but
you start to realize that
of course um you can't ignore the fact
that these things exist and i do have to
work slightly harder to get into other
positions that people that of not my
race might might get easily but that
doesn't necessarily mean that i can't
make something of myself
and and
like nepotism to benefit people around
me because that's just what we do so the
liberal mindset puts you in a state of
you know it's everybody else's fault so
you take no responsibility for for
actions that you commit and you can see
that now we're having a conversation
about women is this liberal ideology
that nothing's ever your fault and you
know there's always something that's
going to come to look after you when in
reality we have structures in place to
prevent these things from happening so
that we don't have to to go to plan b
like it's called the precautionary
principle if you don't understand the
consequences of something you don't do
it but a lot of people don't follow the
precautionary principle when they do
things anyway and it's just going
it goes left but i think
coming on the show
has just helped to
it when i think about how i think now
my values are a lot more conservative
than they are liberal
so really i should just ah so you're
saying this show made you a concern
listen it helps
listen it helped let me just say you
pushed me in the right
i don't know if it's the right direction
but you push me in the direction
i have a quick question for eddie so you
grew up nah did you say nigerian yeah
yeah yeah okay then so um you growing up
nigerian yeah is it because of your
background is that why you think you
fell into the
automatic ideology of liberal
my parents are in this country as a
consequence of that and the support that
the labor government gave at the time so
like my parents now yeah are
automatically labeled no matter what
labor does or whatever they say i
thought it was just my parents as well
yeah literally they're labeled no matter
what happens and
i one of the one of the times was that
the votes happened i've heard green
party because i'm a i'm a big
environmentalist as well and they're
like why would you vote green party vote
labor because you know labor's the only
one that can save us i think they ain't
doing nothing right now yeah i thought
it was only my parents that said that
they they're committed but again like
not saying my parents are
dumb or anything but they're this
ignorant of of the current dynamics of
the world they have their perception of
what they grew up with and that's all
that exists yeah and that's not the
reality of the world we need to make
informed decisions and that's why
democracy doesn't work democracy doesn't
work because you don't have an educated
population to make informed decisions
about current affairs people fall into
this pseudo-cultures of group identities
and then they make the wrong decisions
based on just being a part of a group
yes the world democracy doesn't work
that way and because we live in the
world governed by democracy the world
don't work that way so
people just need to get wiser and
liberalism doesn't do that yeah that's
why women we should give back our right
to vote
i know i don't think i could when the
last voting thing happened i don't think
i was eligible to vote yeah but then
should i have voted yet i don't know if
i would i feel like i would have either
voted to have a green party or democrats
because like i said coming from an
african background as well as a black
female label's not doing nothing my mama
older sister mad that they'd be like yes
let's go for life but yes yes yes let
everybody do an offering and that's what
i think i think i was actually hoping
for the democrats to win
i don't know i think cause i have a
democrats or green party i can't
remember but i know it was one of the
two i wanted them to win you have
democrats here yeah we've got the
liberal democrats oh okay they're the
liberals is it is it the same as the us
liberals no it's slightly different but
basically we got
the what's it we got the labor we got
the conservative and then i think
liberal democrats is in the middle well
but yeah he says it's in the system
again these both parties there's the
problem having a two-party state anyway
but those parties are becoming more
centralized anyway they're essentially
saying the same thing in different ways
so okay
devil's advocate women get back the
right to vote okay
i i don't want to say i believe this but
i think about it okay
women we're chemically different every
single day
and you see the media playing into
getting the women's right to vote
because that's why whenever there's a
big election coming up that's why you
see
like we then there's a big election
coming up in the states in november and
roe versus wade just happened to get
leaked six months before they're trying
to get women to the polls
i'm like we're too easily controlled as
women i think in general
so i always say i'll take one for the
team to get the outcomes that i want
because i think elections would go more
my way the thing is i don't i don't this
as well i've got to be careful saying
what i say but i don't think you're
necessarily wrong in that because
this is part of what i studied at
university as well as information and
decision science so there's a guy called
edward bernays and they call him the
father of pr um
and he was able to manipulate my
psychology to kind of gear in whatever
way he wanted so i think at the time
there was a cigarette company that he
worked for and there's a lot of um i
think the women will find for the rat to
vote et cetera around that time as well
um but he wanted to grow the the sales
of this particular company called lucky
stripe so what did he do he went for the
women so he basically created a campaign
that made the cigarettes a torch of
freedom and then change the color
branding of the cigarettes to the latest
fashion of that year yeah um and with
that skyrocket itself and a lot of the
kind of advertising um
ways that we follow today are from this
guy called edward bernays so he was able
to manipulate my psychology
to boost the sales of this particular
company and that's what they do all the
time well women own two-thirds of
consumer debt
we we make more emotional decisions in
general more impulsive decisions yeah
and it's hard because there are women
like obviously i would imagine if we
took away women's right to vote then the
women couldn't run for office right and
there are women like nikki haley i don't
know if you you you guys probably don't
know who that is but she's a kick-ass
woman i would totally vote for her but
and so but
again i'm like i think we would all take
one for the team
to get the outcomes that we wanted yeah
and the majority of women didn't want
the right to vote
why because it came with responsibility
that's what oftentimes women as women we
want the benefits without the
responsibility
and that's what feminism always does is
they always want the benefits of being a
woman without any of the responsibility
so they don't want to be accountability
they don't take accountability no no and
so it's a parasite so yeah
okay
um but but so with voting you had to be
drafted okay the majority of people
couldn't vote in history in the u.s i
don't i don't know how it worked here
but in the u.s anyway the majority
people couldn't vote
because the aristocrats at a time yeah
because they had to own land
yeah i learned about that yeah so
and women didn't want to be drafted like
i don't know about you guys but if i had
to be drafted or give up my right to
vote i would give up my right to vote
easy i don't want to go to war do you
know what it's funny you say that do you
remember when we heard all this ukraine
versus russia stuff right i started i
saw no feminist tick tocks there he was
there there was loads and the jokers but
they're all saying that well i don't
want to be a feminist no more because if
i have to go to what i'd rather get in
the kitchen and the joke is yeah i
started seeing those little skits of
like women women saying oh me me um
mopping the floors and taking care of
that i'm sorry for everyone my husband
is away i will i'm like oh okay you're
right
have yeah seen the sounds like yes i do
the cooking yes
it's like feminists as soon as any they
have to do any of the hard things that
men have to do
but you know what though they want us to
be plumbers we're running to the kitchen
they're picking their cheese and you're
right they're really picking and
choosing don't do that but what you said
before about um aristocrats having to
vote
those times is when democracy worked at
its best because you had informed people
that were well informed making decisions
for the rest of the rest of the people i
don't think people who are
that don't follow these things who are
you don't understand that the direct and
that the dynamics of life and how things
work in terms of like um political
ideology or things around the world
should have the right to make decisions
for other people because then you just
have a situation where the wrong people
get elected into power through ignorance
and then you all complain at the fact
that these brexit is a perfect example
most people don't want brexit no more
they were all crammed that you know yeah
300 350 million for the nhs blah blah
blah you got lied to you you fell for
the lie
and now you're all upset that the
consequences are you know the the
current living crisis et cetera et
cetera but if people well informed from
the beginning we never would have had
that mistake in the first place right so
society becomes better the more educated
people become so here's why we have
these type of conversations where we
articulate the facts and not just have
basis opinions based on nothing but and
and i think women use this to defend
themselves so that that's why they don't
want us talking about them because
nobody likes to get told that what
you're doing is against the feminine
imperative yeah when we start like you
said we start calling stuff out that's
why they get mad and they can't start
getting all emotional when they want to
destroy this yeah
you hate women
i always say i want to date a misogynist
because then he'll hate all women but me
now that's a good one that's a good one
you should make that a clip
you know what eddie you actually said
something really funny that you said you
love gao and it's true i think us as
guys we want like genuinely we want
nothing more but to protect women and to
like look after you and stuff but how
hard is it to look after someone that's
fighting you like imagine imagine trying
to look like physically imagine
literally trying to let's say you're out
with your girl and some guy is just
being obnoxious and whatever imagine
trying to protect her and she joins him
while she's like fighting you at the
same time how are you supposed to you
know i mean it makes no sense no wonder
like you have mgtow and all those other
groups as well
yeah and that's that's the question like
women want equality right but when um
that plane was crashing in the hudson uh
in the u this was a u.s thing but i
heard about that yeah but who who went
off first the women and the children
because what you have to put women first
yeah
and if we're willing to accept that
then that would be so
if if god forbid that ever happened in
you i'm
running
i was about to be like every man for
themselves i do not care if we're
married every month for themselves you
see me we're gonna be going
you see i'm already dashing off the boat
i'm already dashing i'm dashing i don't
care
i'm personally just dashing we don't
mind we accept our responsibility we
don't mind that's what it is so like if
someone breaks into the house you best
believe i'm up saying yes i've got this
yeah yeah don't worry about it i'ma
punch him up for real
we accept our responsibilities at least
you do the problem is number most men
would want to and again is is this facts
broken family scenario that teaches men
not to be real men like
if you go back to if you go back before
the baby the baby bloomer generation men
behaved like men there wasn't these
conversations never needed to be had
because men knew what they had to do
women knew what they had to do it's not
again and fault of liberalism that
everybody's up in the air that you know
the men are the same as women and women
are the same as men so let's do all the
same [ __ ] that we can do and then what
you do have just women selecting all the
good things and pushing around the bad
things
you have these consequences men want to
be men but a lot of men don't know how
to be men which is why someone like
kevin samuels has such a big
kind of group following because i say
kevin samuels was the father to a lot of
fatherless men
a lot of men are hearing suffering a lot
of this stuff for the first time and
thinking
i needed to know this like why didn't no
one teach me this my mom told me just to
be nice to girls and buy them flowers
but then they called me a [ __ ] so like
so now we're here to actually teach men
listen how this is how you behave as a
man
and women understand that you know
you need to take responsibility for your
actions and hopefully people get better
as a consequence of it but doesn't that
not come back to the divorce rate that
happened in 1960. i don't know if it was
the u.s or the uk but
i think it was now allowed in the 1950s
or 1960s that divorce was allowed to
happen and then no fault divorce put in
no fault divorce i'm guessing
it might it must have been some sort of
thing something along the lines of that
and then before you know it because guys
are allowed to divorce now of
because people are allowed to divorce
now sorry about my slang before you know
it the divorce rate just carricated up
and then from i do want to say at least
the 1970s max you just start seeing some
single parent single parent single
parent and then look at us now 2020.
well do you know you know what also
happened yeah the development of birth
control
i think that was bigger than the divorce
laws
i mean don't get me wrong the the
divorce laws incentivized women to leave
because you can even take half
but
at the end of the day
the
abortion pill changed society forever
because it took away the consequence of
sleeping around before there was a
a big ass consequence if you were
sleeping around yeah
and that's all that's the only thing
that kind of gives feminism its power is
the fact that you do have a plan a
second option that's why women can say
oh we can do what men do now we can
sleep around the same way you sleep
around when the reality again it takes
logic and just rationale to understand
that you're not biologically built to do
that like i think you take a man with
the sperm it produces in the day four
years to impregnate the entire female
population when you can only bring a
baby to to to conception once a month
so i mean once every nine months the
arena
and and the more
the more men you sleep with the less
likely you will have a happy marriage in
10 years like i i think the stat when i
heard the stat that when you're a virgin
you have an 80 chance of having a happy
marriage and when you sleep with more
than five guys it drops to 25 percent
crazy five
yeah just five so your your number
should be five if you're slipping more
than five man
let me just keep it moving it's ready
no that's what that's what they say it's
like around like five to seven is when
for women it drops
steadily like it drops a lot
and
did they say men's numbers like 19.
well they said one girl or one
one partner one body for a girl is the
same as a 19 for a man i don't know if
that's true
other way around so oh yeah yeah my body
for a guy is equated to 19 bodies for a
girl when it comes to pair bonding yeah
which is the idea of two people being
compatible and being able to bond
i think on a spiritual
on a soul level yeah yeah but then we've
got sleeping around doesn't it not go
back to what happens at home at the end
of the day what you was talking about
where um
the whole
home comes society and it comes back to
i want to say the single parent ideology
that he was bringing yeah
well
one thing that was said is that
women don't know what unconditional love
is unless they have they've had that
love from their father that's so true
because often not if a woman has to have
a father in her life that's the only man
that should be in your life that doesn't
actually want anything from you every
man you meet after your father or your
brothers are gonna want something from
you so what women do they go trying to
look for this idea of love or this
unconditional love and they didn't
manifest in promiscuous ways yeah so
we need fathers and kids lives basically
no cup get me mm-hmm
no i'm just a guy i'm clapping because i
agree
i'm gonna read some super chats
um i think this is my most mellow show
i've ever had
you're on holiday it was like a sunday
today just like a national
um okay declan flynn hot take but i feel
is one of the worst i feel okay hot take
but i quote feel that the worst part of
abortion is how it allows women to
operate in the dating marketplace with
eight b
people i'm not concerned with that it's
murder arguments
bobo won't kill us off one billion lost
men will um
oh so he's saying that basically the
worst part of abortion is how it allows
women to move because it's just the
ultimate form of hypergamy
so it's like a smaller and smaller
percentage of men get to reproduce
yep
um okay
winky pig yes women are highly
suggestible and strongly influenced by
peer pressure oh my don't don't tempt me
this might be sir this might be my new
don't tempt me this might be my new take
someone put me on the map
don't tempt me don't tempt me okay
my mom had me at 21 and my dad
and with my dad she wasn't dating and
never married him but later married my
stepdad that accepted us
but she wanted an abortion but ended up
keeping me realizing it was a life
lesson from my grandma telling her winky
pig i hear that feminists are having and
promoting abortion parties which is
quite frankly sick
have you seen those tick tocks where
girls are celebrating getting their
abortion yeah yeah i'm not gonna lie i
pressed uh you see they're not not
interested things don't show me that
because you just took away life like
what are you doing yeah you celebrate
that yeah how can you celebrate that at
least like why do you think it's all
right to show the whole world that i
don't think that's cool man
summers are popping that's where step
daddy season
hey yes sir
um black women in the usa have the most
deletions per capita isn't that number
crazy 474 for every thousand
births yeah are aborted that just shows
how powerful genders can be
yeah that worked successfully
and it's just
it blows my mind that this isn't on
every news cycle yeah because imagine if
nike was started that way
yeah
yeah like i mean obviously not they
can't provide abortions but if they were
had super racist founders that would be
everywhere
but for some reason planned parenthood
it's not
um but then again as like eddie said
earlier everything is like geared
towards women so this is just another
thing geared for them
to them so it's like if
anything to kind of say oh
yo this is wrong yeah you know i mean
they're not going to highlight but
thankfully
we're here you know amongst other people
yeah because it goes back to what paul
said yeah when um she said how we're two
friends of this of the markets consumer
is it am i right paul two fives
uh that's 60 right 66.6
where is what wait sorry what's that did
you say um where women are two thirds of
the market consumer oh we make 70 to 80
percent of consumers yes that's yeah
yeah so and then obviously you are right
like it comes back to us women at the
end of the day i didn't make up i put
also welcome john march to our
membership program
you'll get to see me beat-ish in a bad
behind-the-scenes this week
raise your reflexes
things happen
we take l's we take lessons from them
um and that's what it is yeah i don't
think she looks happy yes do you want to
make another okay
yes she wanted to make another bet on on
live you're gone when do you think we'll
hit
two hundred thousand
um i'll let you pick first
shiver is not dead
i've learned but i asked i asked you for
yes ladies first wait
you know how this works ladies first
okay what does the chat say um
what do you think okay i'm gonna say
at the rate we're going
[Music]
uh i'm gonna say july 15th
wow
i was going to say the exact same number
i was going to say you should have went
first well i think
there was no rule saying that we could
be the same day
no no you can't because i ain't i i'm
inserting a new rule
after the fact
come on pick it a day before our day
after
what's on the line
okay let's see same bet perhaps we'll
ask a job
absolutely not
we'll we'll take we'll take this behind
the scenes
and
you'll get to see what actually happened
yeah
um okay also and super chat from tab man
i love the show as a black male londoner
i've been going through the same motions
from liberal to conservative glad to see
the other guys in this country are
waking up
okay um well i think i'm gonna wrap up
the show because i literally am out of
stats
okay um so what do you go around and say
if you're pro-life or pro-choice
at the end of this and if you're still
undecided you can say that too
um but
and tell the people where they can find
you
so
yeah i don't live by exceptions i live
by the rule so just given that i'm
pro-life because a lot of my
yeah i'm pro-life to make sure it's in
um because the right one
my opinions fall towards that um
that's where you can find me i've
changed my i changed my act now so it's
at it's at who's underscore eddie
underscore so hit me up follow me um i'm
double half of the domino effect podcast
so you can see me and more my stuff on
there um and yeah that's me
all right then so um you know after
pearl hitting the stats and have and
after having conversation with these
wonderful lovely people shout out to you
guys you lots are amazing um no problem
i'm pro-life i've made my decision
yeah you guys can find me on instagram
at ofc unscored zera nana tasha follow
me there and if you want to have a
continued conversation
about this i'm actually up for a healthy
debate and yeah
i mean
thanks to pearl and the panel i'm now
pro-life
growth growth um yeah you can find me on
instagram and it's teex's fault
i feel like this is like alcoholics
anonymous
um so yeah i'm daniel um i'm definitely
pro-life you can find me at
manjie the man underscore manji with a j
um and yeah i talk about all things
men's lifestyle all that stuff and yeah
that's me
also we also got a new member
oinky oinky pig
sign up to see ish lose this next bet
again
we're we're gonna i'm gonna make him
pick a date and just two so can i come
what
someone has to lose and if there's four
people there's more money
whoever's the furthest away has to buy
everyone else dinner
yeah money's getting lost that's what
i'm going to say your money in london as
well yeah it's expensive guys
inflation is a real thing
recession is
coming all right
okay guys um don't forget to subscribe
to the channel like the video on your
way out the like liking the video is so
important to the algorithm so if you
can't send a super chat can't join the
memberships literally like the video it
helps so much don't forget to subscribe
to the channel ring that notification
bell and i will talk to you next time